لديكم شهر واحد فقط لتنفد
اسلحتكم وهجومكم محكوم بالفشل.
هكذا تقولها واشنطن صراحة في وجه
اوكرانيا ومصر تدخل خط الحرب
الاوكرانية وتمد روسيا بالاسلحة
والذخائر. فهل فعلها الفراعنة
وامريكا لقد كشفنا جاسوسا روسيا
وهو من سرب الوثائق السرية.
ومدينة اوكرانية اخرى تبدأ
بالاستسلام بشكل جماعي. وتصريحات
عسكرية من رئيسة تايوان نحو
الصين. وبعد ان انهت بكين تحرشت
العسكرية. الفلبين مع امريكا
تدشنان اول تحرك عسكري تجاه
الصين. فما الذي يجري زعيم كوريا
الشمالية يغلق سماعة هاتفه في
وجه امريكا وكوريا الجنوبية.
وايرلندا تنقذ حياة الرئيس
الامريكي من حادثة اغتيال وشيكة
وسوريا تعود للاحضان العربية.
حرب التسريبات تشتعل. صمد
الاوكران امام الضربات الخارجية
من الروسي. لكن عندما تأتي
الضربة من الاصدقاء والحلفاء
يكون اثرها بالغا على الجسد
الاوكراني لتأتي طعنة الغدر من
الامريكان هذه المرة حيث لا تزال
قضية تسريب وثائق امريكية فائقة
السرية تتفاعل في واشنطن والعديد
من عواصم الدول الحليفة. وهنا
تظهر وثيقة مسربة جديدة لتعلن ان
الاستخبارات الامريكية تعلم ان
الهجوم الاوكراني المرتقب هذا
الربيع لن يحقق اهدافه بل ان
التقييمات الامريكية حذرت مما
سمته نواقص في حشد القوات
الاوكرانية وامدادها وفقا
لواشنطن بوست. واما الضربة
القوية للوثائق فكان حين تم
الكشف عن خسارة كييف لدفاعاتها
الجوية بالكامل. حيث سينفد
مخزونها من صواريخ باك واس
ثلاثمائة وبطاريتين سماس وبطارية
بحلول مايو وقت فعن اي ضربة
نتحدث هل تهبط هذه التسريبات من
معنويات الاوكران لتعلن خسارتهم
ولا تزال قضية التسريبات هي
الشغل الشاغل للامريكيين
وحلفائهم حيث فجرت الصحيفة
الامريكية قنبلة من نوع اخر.
وذلك بان احدى الوثائق المسربة
ذكرت ان الرئيس المصري امر
بانتاج اربعين الف صاروخ ليتم
شحنها سرا الى روسيا الى خطط
لتزويد روسيا بقذائف المدفعية
والبارود. بينما قال مسؤول في
الحكومة الامريكية للصحيفة ان
واشنطن ليست على علم بتنفيذ خطة
تزويد مصر لروسيا بالصواريخ ولم
ترى ذلك يحدث. فهل يتجرأ
الفراعنة ليكون اول دولة عربية
تعلن دعمها العسكري للدب الروسي؟
هنا جاءت الاجابة من متحدث
الكرملين ديمتري بسكوب. ان
الانباء حول خطط مزعومة لمصر
لتزويد روسيا بالاف الصواريخ سرا
هي تلفيق اخر لذا يجب التعامل مع
مثل هذه التقارير على هذا
الاساس. مضيفا ان علاقات مصر
وروسيا تشهد تعاونا كبيرا على
اكثر من صعيد على رأسها
الاقتصادي. لكن لا يوجد اي تعاون
عسكري من هذا القبيل وفق قوله.
كان نفسي اغني والله وعملوها
الرجالة. هل ستترك مصر فلسطين
وتدعم روسيا برأيكم؟ هنا امريكا
تكتشف جاسوسا روسيا. وليس بشريا
بل الالكتروني. حيث تشير
التحقيقات الامريكية الى ان
التسريبات تمت عبر تطبيق ديسكورد
الخاصة بمجتمع العاب الفيديو
لتعلن صحيفة الديلي ميل
البريطانية ان المحققين سينظرون
في الادلة التي تظهر في هوامش
الصور والتي يمكن ان تساعد في
كشف هوية بينما ينصب التركيز في
الولايات المتحدة حاليا على ان
التسريب هو شأن امريكي. لكون
كثير من الوثائق كانت بايدي
الامريكيين فقط بحسب وكالة
روترز. انني اشتم رائحة خيانة
وهذه الخيانة في الداخل يا ابناء
العم سام. وها هو جون كيربي
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
في البيت الابيض يصرح بان حجم
ضرر الوثائق المسربة للامن
القومي الامريكي غير معروف مداه.
مضيفا ان واشنطن ستواصل دعم
اوكرانيا حتى بعد تسريب الوثائق
السرية. ومن حرب المعلومات
والتسريبات الى اصداء اصوات
القنابل والمدافع. حيث افادت
هيئة الاركان الاوكرانية بصد
قواتها اثنين وخمسين هجوما
للقوات الروسية على محاور باخموت
وليمان وافدي ييفكا ومارينكا
بمقاطعة دونيسك شرقي اوكرانيا.
ان القصف الروسي ما زال مستمرا
على مقاطعتي خيرسون وزابوروجيا
جنوبي البلاد. بالمقابل اكد
الجيش الاوكراني ان قواته قصفت
مواقع للقوات الروسية في ريف
زبورتيا الجنوبي. الحرب تستعر
اكثر يا سادة ليؤكد مؤسس قوات
فاغمر الروسية الملقب بطباخ
بوتين ان ثمانين بالمائة من
باخموت تخضع لسيطرة القوات
الروسية. اعلن ايجور كيماغوفسكي
مستشار القائم باعمال رئيس
جمهورية دونتس الروسية ان القوات
الاوكرانية بدأت بالاستسلام بشكل
جماعي في مدينة اف دييفكا
بالجمهورية. لينتقل الروس الى
مجلس الامن الدولي والذي هو تحت
سيطرة روسيا لمدة شهر. حيث عقدت
جلسة دعت اليها روسيا لمناقشة
المخاطر الناجمة عن انتهاك
الاتفاقيات المنظمة لتصدير
الاسلحة معدات العسكرية. وقال
المندوب الروسي الدائم لدى
المجلس ان الدول الغربية تواصل
الدعوة لمبدأ التصرف المسئول.
اضافة الى الحد من نشر السلاح
لكنها في الصراع الذي دفعت به في
اوكرانيا اثبتت عدم صدق تصريحات
مسؤوليها على حد تعبيره. المحيط
الهادئ لا يهدأ. لا صوت يعلو فوق
صوت الاسلحة في بحر الصين
الجنوبي وضجيج المحركات الحربية
لا يتوقف لتندلع التحرشات
العسكرية. نعم وبعد ان انهت بكين
تدريباتها هناك بدأت الفلبين
والولايات المتحدة تحرشاتهما
العسكرية باكبر مناورات عسكرية
مشتركة بينهما والتي تشمل لاول
مرة تدريبات بالذخيرة الحية،
وذلك لمواجهة الاصرار الصيني
المتزايد في المنطقة. هذه
التدريبات سنوية يا اصدقاء وليست
وليدة اللحظة. لكن هذه المرة
يشارك فيها ضعف القوات التي كانت
فيها العام الماضي بمشاركة ما
يقرب من ثمانية عشر الف جندي
فيما يطلق عليها اسم بلاكي تان
او كتفا بكتف في الفلبين. فهل
هناك من رد صيني وهنا لا يوقف
اصحاب العيون الضيقة تحركاتهم
اساسا؟ لتعلن وزارة الدفاع
التايوانية انها رصدت ما يقل عن
تسع سفن حربية وست وعشرين طائرة
مقاتلة صينية في محيط الجزيرة
رغم انتهاء مناورات الصين الضخمة
التي اطلقت عليها السيف المشترك
مؤكدة ان بكين حشدت طائرات
عسكرية وعبرت خط الوسط من الشمال
والوسط والجنوب. وكأن بكين تأبى
ان تعود خالية الوفاض. فهل
تستعيد الصين جزيرتها رئيسة
تايوان تصمت وعبرت عن غضبها
العارم بقولها ان المناورات
الصينية ليست طريقة مسؤولة من
قبل دولة كبرى والجيش ومؤسسات
الامن ستبقى في حالة تأهب للدفاع
عن البلاد رغم انتهاء المناورات
الصينية وفق رويترز. الاحداث
والتطورات. اعرب التسيغول عن
اسفها الشديد ازاء رفض كوريا
الشمالية الرد على المكالمات
اليومية عبر خط اتصال الكوريتين
وخط عسكري ساخن. معتبرة ان ذلك
تحركا احادي الجانب وغير مسئول.
ما الذي تريده كوريا الجنوبية من
كيم جونغ علم كل تلك الاتصالات.
قالت الشرطة في ايرلندا الشمالية
انها عثرت على اربع قنابل في
مقبرة بالقرب من ديري جاء ذلك
قبل ساعات من وصول الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن الى الاراضي
الايرلندي. فهل كان هنالك تحضير
لعملية اغتيال لجو بايدن اكد
نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجية
الامريكية ضرورة الحفاظ على
الوضع التاريخي الراهن للاماكن
المقدسة في القدس وحرية ممارسة
العقيدة للجميع. بينما خرج
مؤيدون للقضية الفلسطينية في
تظاهرات بعدة مدن غربية في كندا
وامريكا وبريطانيا منددين
بانتهاكات الاحتلال في المسجد
الاقصى في شهر رمضان المبارك.
اذا فماذا الدول المطبعة تبحث
الامانة العامة لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي امكانية عودة سوريا الى
جامعة الدول العربية خلال اجتماع
يوم الجمعة المقبل في مدينة جدة
بالسعودية. وافادت مصادر
الدبلوماسية ان الاجتماع سيطرح
امكانية مشاركة دمشق في القمة
العربية المقبلة. الوثائق تغرق
الامريكان اكثر. وتلمح لاقتراب
نهاية المقاومة الاوكرانية
برأيكم. اهي وثائق سقطت بسبب
اختراق للاستخبارات الامريكية ام
انها طعم لاعداء واشنطن.